this is the so stay hotel in the Polish
city of Gdansk although it might look
like an ordinary hotel on the outside
inside it's a hotel with a difference
it's a socially conscious hotel the
hotel employees and trains young people
who've had a difficult start in life
they all grew up in care or foster homes
yeah yeah the desert arm or the trolley
vehicle a bit master that he has
completely forgot Amanda the Tigers of
the vision of the Democrats but
información sobre la Falaise honest in
being I think we're done yet the project
was given a helping hand to get off the
ground by the European Social Fund a
program which supports tens of thousands
of projects like so stay across the EU
with the successes of the fund the ESF
is set to evolve Parliament wants to see
the ESF merge with four other funds and
programs to create the ESF plus
simplifying the e used tools to fight
inequality the new fund will bring
financial support for youth employment
children social inclusion Health and
Social Innovation all of this under one
umbrella making it the main channel for
EU investment in people también los
fondos seda Deacon a los meses para SE
dos ela in sativa I guarantee avenue san
Remos mas flexibility is aramis facil
trabajar con todos los problemas the aim
of the ESF bus is to create a fairer
more resilient Europe where all citizens
are given equal opportunities and have
access to education training and
employment whatever their background the
changes will also make the distribution
and request for funds easier and faster
[Music]